you're on a very funny show called wreck
thank you very much and and and so I
know that you and I've watched you work
and I like this is a very funny guy what
I didn't know is that when you a younger
man even younger than you are now you
were very much into music music was your
passion growing up music was my first
love my first big ambition I I started
in sixth grade I voluntarily joined an
extracurricular club called the boys
quintet it was me and four other little
nerdy white kids and we had a very cool
black music teacher who tried his best
to like give us rhythm and help us be
what what the hell's for that man what
hell for that man patience of a saint
yeah mr. green he was fantastic I loved
him and and we we tried to do like
barbershop music right so we only
learned one song he could only get us to
do one song it was in the still of the
night you know yeah right don't sing - I
won't do - we'll have to pay for it my
party Led Zeppelin what's the most
expensive song I can sing let's sing the
White Album together by the Beatles yeah
just go should OOP shooby-dooby I won't
do any melody I don't get you in trouble
but I just should do crew be doop that's
all I got was all you got to do there's
this kid Michael Salvatori who's sang
the whole song and I stood behind him
and I should duped and I hated him that
was my job so what we would do gigs I'm
in sixth grade seventh grade we would go
to the mall in the middle of the day we
would go to the food court mr. green
would line us up and he would just say
to anyone eating the boys quintet and
then we would sing in the still of the
night and then leave and people would be
like we would go to like food courts of
office buildings and at their lunch but
anywhere if people were eating lunch we
would sing in the still of the night and
all you had to do was say should be do I
should do should be do that was my whole
thing I would get in the car with these
guys yeah sing one song to strangers who
didn't want us why here's my question
why didn't you ever learn what if
someone liked that and was like let's
hear another one we would have been
mortified no one wanted to hear another
one okay I see heard yeah and you're
also in a punk band is that right so
like I was in the nerdiest thing you
could ever be in the
quintet and like when you pull someone
so far into I'm sorry I'm like it my god
that's right no I sling shouted the
other way in high school and I got super
into punk-rock DC's got a great punk
scene I've got two shows all the time I
was in this band where we didn't learn
any songs we would just get a gig and
then the drummer would go look good good
and then me and the other three singers
would roll on the ground and scream into
the microphone until somebody came and
stopped us that was the whole conceit
with nothing I mean just I mean it
sounds horrible I mean it was kind of by
design horrible yeah like it was awful
right terrible you were like giving your
finger to the system sort of you know so
stupid I was I was a kid yeah this mr.
green still booking your game should
have screamed shoo be doop on the floor
you